[Music]  you know what they call trees in the  forest fire  fuel you know what they call the trees  left up when the fire goes by they  called them the standing dead monster is  dead okay  of course he is his pride got hurt that  happens sometimes  you don't have to worry about anything  Joe there comes a time when man needs  something more to hang his hat on got  this homicide my head I need to do  something about it  you understand I think your father has a  woman out here he wouldn't do that  no why do you think that do things they  need to go crazier it's a woman  [Music]  are the best true people are drawn to  things they shouldn't be  I was dressed like this all the time  when I was younger there I was probably  nice to know your parents when once  night your parents  does your mother do something that you  would like to have to tell me about  I feel like  [Music]  what's going to happen to us  [Music]  [Music]  you